[Music]
um everyone I'm sorry should I have your
attention please thank you
hi sorry I just have an announcement to
make
um
okay I have learned a lot about Indian
culture tonight
but I have learned even more
about love
and I know you're all thinking who is
this crazy Gringo and what is he talking
about well I'm not crazy
maybe I'm crazy in love
so without further ado
Carol
Carol stills
I would like you to do me the honor
of making me your husband
Michael what are you saying
can we talk about this in private I
didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
are you kidding
yeah
[Music]
what is this
that is my Christmas card it's a picture
of you and me and your kids on a ski
trip having a blast skeezing's greetings
no see we never went on a ski trip I
know I went on a ski trip right two
years ago with my kids and my ex-husband
yes but what you didn't realize at the
time was that I was with you in a sense
I was in your heart and next to your
kids what this is so weird
I don't understand it's a bold move to
photoshop yourself into a picture with
your girlfriend and her kids on a ski
trip with a real father
but then again Michael's a bold guy
is bold the right word I think you're a
really sweet guy okay but um
deal with
with this thing and and the proposal and
I don't think things are gonna work out
with us okay okay you know what you're
not thinking straight
you know you need you need
to think this through in
Jamaica's largest freshwater pool
what are you talking about I got us
vandals Jamaica
find the skip
this Michael and it's all inclusive
Michael yes
I'm sorry
no Carol you walk out that door and it
is over I know
uh hi Pam Halpert yes hi uh I'm Clark uh
Josie said you might benefit from a
lactation consultant
um yeah yeah that would be great really
great okay once you available actually
uh I'm the consultant
got milk
all right let's see what we're working
with
so uh the biggest thing besides not
being able to get her to latch oh thank
you is that um I can't tell if I'm
really producing I I don't know if she's
getting anything I feel here okay yeah
it's quite full once you put your hand
on top of my hand okay when you're
feeding you want to press in like this
make your hand in the C does that hurt
no I mean it feels pressure okay sure it
doesn't hurt no okay it just feels like
pressure you know I'm flicking the
nipple like that yeah you can stimulate
it yep
all right so you just want to do that
and that will uh perfect and you can
just the baby should grab onto that I
think she will so I'm just not sure if
I'm releasing though I'm not sure if
I'll figure it out it doesn't why don't
you bring your baby over here okay
he's beautiful oh thank you
congratulations thank you
well you're doing a good job just stay
relaxed and I'll come back in a bit to
check on you okay okay please do
oh shoot
she fell off oh okay try try the torpedo
thing will you just will you grab Clark
real quick no need I saw him do it I can
try it
um please please I think it would be
weird if you did it
that makes sense we'll just go get the
other one
so
everybody else
a place so thanks for the loop yeah sure
I'll um I'll see you tonight
oh easy tiger I just really like you
okay bye guys nice to meet you you have
a great day
whoa Toby watch out you're gonna violate
your own PDA memo I wouldn't want to do
that
would I
well you know Michael I have a brother
in Boulder Rory flanderson should look
him up
okay
here's the thing Rory I think you guys
were hit it off in an odd way
bring him a welcome basket
hey uh well you should give them a
little time to settle in but does he
like jams my shelves are overflowing
with preserves
well no he hates jams Pam what was in
the teapot letter
oh um well you know I I just I think I
would rather keep that private
you know if you've been filmed for nine
years of your life there would be some
things that you just want to keep to
yourself I hear you what did it say
we're gonna move on next question please
do you find that your life feels
pointless now that nobody's actually
filming you anymore
yes
I want to know how everyone felt they
were portrayed was it accurate I got a
beef with that
um for the first seven years I was
getting my PhD in school psychology and
they didn't show it yes I was getting
hammered but hey it was College
next week at the Scranton Cultural
Center don't forget Irish step dancing
semifinals winning team to Mid-Atlantic
[Applause]
so
how are you awesome I am dating a lot of
guys good a lot black eyes mostly Kelly
what
I want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what I want Kelly I'm
your boss now okay you can't keep
talking to me like I'm your boyfriend oh
big strong man fancy new whatever I
don't think you ever cared about me I
never cared about you six months ago
Karen filipelli sent me an email asked
me out I said no because I was committed
to our relationship well I hope you're
still committed because I'm pregnant
and guess what buddy I am keeping it
okay okay do you feel prepared to help
me raise a baby
I can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner we'll
talk about it then okay
we have a date
hey Kelly what's up nothing oh except oh
my God Jim last night Ryan and I totally
finally hooked up it was awesome that's
great I'm really happy first I know and
it was so funny because we were at this
bar with his friend and I was sitting
next to him the whole night and it
wasn't making a move so in my head I was
like Ryan what's taking you so long and
then he kissed me and I didn't know what
to say so I said Ryan what took you so
long and you just said it to him can you
believe that wow oh my God Jim is that
embarrassing I'm embarrassed no don't be
no thank God because I was nervous Jim
you will not believe I was so nervous
but now now I have a boyfriend
I hooked up with her on February 13th
all right